[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAUREN JOYCE: So today
we're here with Arcules.
And Arcules is seeing into
actionable intelligence.
Arcules, a Canon group,
launched about a year ago
from incubation and today
is launching their product
into market.
The Arcules Video Cloud platform
combines enterprise video
and IoT sensor data,
leveraging cloud technologies
and analytics to turn
information streams
into insights for businesses,
optimizing operations,
and improving safety.
So, with that, I'll hand
it over to Sheriff and Ben
to tell you more.
SHERIFF MOHAMED:
Thank you, Lauren.
LAUREN JOYCE: You're welcome.
SHERIFF MOHAMED: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Oh, seriously?
Come on.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
Thank you.
Awesome.
So I am Sheriff Mohamed,
the principal engineer.
I run the engineering
department for Arcules.
I have Ben here, who is our
cloud and security architect.
So we get to blame him for
everything that's not working.
BEN ROWE: Pretty much.
[LAUGHTER]
SHERIFF MOHAMED:
Clicker, come on.
There we go.
So, what do we do?
So our roots really start from
video surveillance on premise.
And the idea was is that we
wanted to take that and put
that into the cloud.
And with that thought, we
were kind of building out
the product and everything.
We realized that you could do
so much more than just video
surveillance in the cloud.
And with, especially,
the power of AI and IoT
and that correlation
of the data, we
realized there's
so much more there.
So we're boldly trying to create
a new category by the name
of Video IoT as a service--
Video Cloud IoT as a
service, excuse me.
And what we're going to
talk about today is real.
It's not vaporware.
These are a few
screenshots of our product,
our dashboard, and
some of the insights
that you're able to see
when you are clicking around
in the application.
So I want you guys to
dream a little bit with me.
All right?
Imagine if there
was a way for us
to be able to detect a school
shooting when it's happening,
or prior to the fact that
it happens through sound
and other IoT devices,
that we can lock down
the school immediately
and react immediately.
Or what if there was a lost
child at an amusement park
and we could find that lost
child based on what color
shirt it was wearing
or pants or whatever,
or even a bracelet that it may
have through beacon technology?
Thank you.
All right.
What if we're able to maximize
the ad revenue that retailers
have through real-time
shopper analytics
to see how their shoppers
are actually interacting
with the products and within
the store-- their traffic
and all of that.
So our goal is to revolutionize
video and IoT intelligence
and bring that together, from
this era of unstructured data--
very forensic-- and
after-the-fact type
of thing to more of a structured
and preventative and a way
to be able to react on the spot.
Let me explain a little bit
more about what the unstructured
versus structured data is.
So unstructured data is
very blobby and homogeneous,
just like water flowing.
It's just going
through, into the cloud.
You can't really do
anything with it,
unless you have some
sort of human element,
human interaction with
it to tell you what it
is that's actually happening.
Now, there are ways to be
able to detect disturbances
in that field, such
as motion detection.
But it still doesn't
give you enough.
You still need a human
there to tell you, oh, that
was just a bug--
literally, a bug
flying on the camera.
Or it was a blurry
camera screen.
Or it was actually a
human doing something.
Right?
And, again, it's reactive.
It happens after the fact.
So with the advent of AI
and bringing everything up
into the cloud, we're
able to add more structure
to that data, be
able to tell you
what is actually in the
video that you are seeing.
Such as in this scenario,
we're able to see there
are six people running.
You know, that's great.
We're able to know that there
are actually six people there.
We know it's not
a blurry screen.
We know there's no smudge
there or something.
But we know there
are six people.
However, they're running.
Why are they running?
We don't know exactly why.
We still don't
have enough context
to be able to react
to that, right?
So we need a little bit more.
That's where IoT
comes in and being
able to correlate all
of that data together.
So in this particular
scenario, we
know that six people running.
We know they weren't exercising
because it seemed like there
was a big spike in temperature.
All right.
We don't know what that spike
in temperature was because of.
It could be a fire.
More than likely, it's a fire.
But we're going to be proactive
and go sound the alarm so we
get more and more people
out of the building
to save lives and
things like that.
And then, after the
fact, we can always
figure out, forensics-wise,
who, what, where, why, and when.
OK.
Now, as I said, all of
this stuff you can actually
do today with our product.
Again, this is a quick demo
of our product on the left
there, with all that scrolling.
You see our dashboard
and our web portal
where you can manage settings
and things like that, also
view video.
The middle portion-- that
is our thick client that
is used by 24-7
operations, that you
can see actual, real-time
AI events come in through.
And then on the
furthest right side--
my right-- that is our iOS
or Android app where you
could actually view live video.
So with that, I'm going
to pass it over to Ben
and he'll talk to you guys about
architecture and high-level
how we do this.
BEN ROWE: Cool.
Thank you.
Cool.
Hey, guys.
So we use a variety of
technologies in our platform.
We have Go lang, Node.js, React,
Python for TensorFlow stuff,
as well as some C code.
We're kind of polyglot.
We kind of give our
engineers the ability
to use the tools that they
need to solve the problem,
rather than just trying to smash
a square peg in a round hole.
It doesn't really work
very well when you
try to get into that situation.
We also use Kubernetes.
I'm going to talk
a little bit more
about that in the
next few slides.
Kubernetes is awesome.
I don't know whether you
guys are familiar with it.
But GKE and we also happen to
have Kubernetes at the edge
as well.
Very interesting.
And then, finally,
obviously, why we're all here
is Google Cloud.
They've been awesome
to us as partners.
We have literally
two, three pages
worth of requests or problems
that we're trying to solve.
And Trish and Juan
over there have
been awesome being able to
solve all of our problems.
The other reason why we
also use Google Cloud--
we tested out several
different cloud platforms.
I can't mention their names.
But, at the end of
the day, it came down
to speed and reliability.
And Google won hands-down.
There was no question about it.
There was-- when you're
dealing with video,
such a high, intense
kind of data flow,
there's not one
dropped packet or, oh,
it's 10 seconds too late
by the time it gets there.
We can't react quick enough.
And so that's why we chose
Google as our cloud partner.
Cool.
So, a quick overview
of our solution.
We have a variety
of methods of input,
I guess, is the best
way of putting it.
So we have a mobile app, which
is mostly used by our security
guards, just roaming
security guards,
running around, trying to
figure out what's going on.
They'll get notifications and
alarms to their cell phone.
We have our web client.
A lot of different things
are done through there.
Pretty much the entire--
anything you can do
in our thick client,
you can also do
in our web client.
We have a thick client,
which is more traditional.
That's where you have kind
of your normal sort of--
trying to think of the word.
I can't remember it.
I'm sorry.
Huh?
- Security operations.
BEN ROWE: Security
operations center--
I can't remember the word.
But it's all good.
So mostly they'll be
using that product.
High, lots of volume video,
normally 32 cameras up
on one big screen.
And then, kind of get down
into the IoT side of things,
and the actual
device side, right?
So, cameras-- as
we are effectively
out of incubation
for milestone, we
actually support
about 6,000 cameras,
primarily through
the ONVIF protocol,
which, if you're familiar
with security cameras,
that's very large for us, along
with a variety of very specific
device drivers for the cameras.
Our IoT device platform
is completely extensible.
Although it's not fully
open-platform yet,
it will eventually
be open platform,
so we can plug into
any IoT vendor on prem,
as well as potentially
cloud-to-cloud integrations
in the future.
Access control is
another huge one,
obviously being able to react,
lock down doors or open up
doors, or video
verification-- hey,
someone passed
through this door.
Hey, what's going on?
It's pretty interesting.
And then, finally, our
third-party integrations.
It's not fully open yet.
We are planning on releasing
a fully open API platform.
It's very interesting
being able to integrate
with other sources of data.
We don't know what they are yet.
But that's where like
being able to pull in
like unstructured data
into structured data
and having all these
feeds of structured data,
we can do so much
more, whether it
be analytics over
the top of that
or whether it's just
reactive elements.
OK, so here's our architecture.
GKE in the cloud, obviously,
I talked about before.
And, also, we actually run
Kubernetes at the edge.
And it's something I kind
of saved for this slide.
Kubernetes is very,
very interesting.
It allows us to deploy
micro services at the edge,
as well as in the cloud.
And then you're much quicker
at reacting, from a devop
standpoint, being able
to fix certain things,
but also being able to
deploy upgrades on the fly--
they go down, they come up--
with very little interruption
to the customer.
There's no longer you're
downloading firmware updates
or Windows updates.
It's all kind of just done live
and switched hot-swappable.
It's great.
Being able to do that
on a security platform
is insanely useful, is
the best way I can put it.
Cool.
So, a quick, high-level view.
We have a video micro service
that sits on the edge.
That's actually where all
our camera drivers live.
So it's all of our data
in, which is unstructured,
which then pushes it
to the video proxy.
Our proxy, then, manages--
we use Google Storage.
We store all that stuff there.
We then have our AI-ML
flow and workflow.
We convert our unstructured
data to structured data,
as Sheriff said earlier.
We also have our IoT devices.
Again, all the
drivers and devices
live down there, at the edge.
All the devices connect
on prem or on the cloud.
It does live on the
GKE side as well.
But, primarily, right now
it's all at the gateway.
We use Cloud IoT Core.
Obviously, that's one
of the big things here.
It saved us about a
month of development time
building off of IoT Core.
It's already hardened.
It's already secure.
We use the MQTT socket base,
if anyone is interested.
We don't use HTTP push.
It just had all the features
we needed at the time.
And the fact that
it automatically
supported private-public key
exchange and all that stuff,
it just made so much sense.
Obviously, with
Cloud IoT, we use
pub-sub to transport
all of our messages,
similar to RabbitMQ and Kafka,
just messaging platform.
And then the next
one is our processor.
How many of you guys
have heard of GDPR?
How many of you
have to deal with it
in like actual, real life?
So one of the interesting
things with IoT data
is you don't actually
know what kind of data
is actually coming in.
We've built a platform
with our drivers.
We actually have to categorize
that data before it comes in.
And we actually have to
pause out and make sure
that we can utilize it
in certain situations.
So we've got a whole
framework and legal framework
around this, separate pieces
which allow us to say, hey,
if this data is coming
in from Germany,
it can't leave the country,
so we have to store it
in a German data center--
that kind of rules-based
engine, based on geolocation.
It's pretty intense.
It was pretty interesting find.
So that's how we
kind of handled that,
just by classifying the data,
and then being able to move it.
And then, based on
that classification,
depending on what we can do
with it, we can either store it.
We can just drop it.
We store all of our
historical data in BigQuery.
That's where we can do
statistical analysis over time.
But we also then like to
pass some of that information
onto our real-time engine, which
is an in-house built function
as a service style system.
We can choose to send
it to this or not.
Obviously, anyone
familiar with some
of the legal
ramifications of GDPR,
you may not be able
to pass it to users.
So we may actually
have to just drop it
before it even gets there.
So the real-time
engine-- what it can do
are taking multiple sensors.
So it could be coming
from our AI-ML services.
It could be coming
from our IT services.
And we can kind of, based
on a series set of rules,
or potentially replumb it
back into any kind of engine.
So it's kind of an
anything-to-anything engine.
We have sent away.
But we can kind of take in lots
of different types of data,
and then either reprocess
it in a different form,
or then take that form and
then action upon it back out,
either via an IoT data sensor,
or change a configuration
somewhere on our
platform to help provide
more actionable insights.
[MUSIC PLAYING]